the following contains explicit language
you should be ashamed for watching that
baliker for reason TV here at the
Hollywood improv we're going to see the
nabi comedy show hosted by sam tripoli I
love Charlie Sheen
dude that guy can do anything you can do
whatever it doesn't shock us anymore
seriously he could be in blackface and
the Mussolini costume Bach and Taylor
Swift and still we just be like Oh
Charlie first off if there's any kids
watching this at home right now if
you're watching the naughty show you
have bad parents we checked that you're
naughty comedy show it's pretty wild
pretty naughty tell the good people of
reason TV about that I grew up on like I
said Sam Kinison Richard Pryor Andrew
Dice Clay was this like rock and roll
kind of comedy vibe where like when they
came to town it was a big event and
people knew there was gonna be chaos and
fun and that's I don't see that anymore
so I decided to create the naughty
comedy show just a two hour comedy party
with a adult film stars pole dancing and
comics doing jokes they can't do on TV
and wild crazy characters I've created
with a friend of mine Jason Tebow tell
me how you got into this dirty business
of stand-up comedy I've always wanted to
be a Sam comic since consciousness
I remember being about two years old and
having like some vacuum cleaner come guy
come over salesman when they still did
that and remember throwing down the
banana and trying to show him how funny
it was me trying to slip on it it's
always been in my blood and I've always
been a kind of a troublemaker
I enjoy chaos and it's very hard to do
that in an office setting now these kids
with the internet by 12 we've already
seen a chick a cup where do you go from
there
where do you go from there honestly man
you know I feel bad for the girls
growing up expectation of what they got
to do now what is second base now this
thing it's getting weird the rise of the
Internet is that changing anything it's
the greatest thing that ever happened it
is the greatest thing that ever happened
like I do my podcast now the night show
podcast
the suits can't control or you know
handicap the game and force you to only
see these people the Internet is like
you can find your crowd if you work hard
enough you put out good enough product
you can find a crowd night and it's the
best thing that ever happened and you're
a national headline or an international
headline or a year oh yeah big deal when
you go to Texas versus California versus
maybe the UK different things set the
audience off what are the things that
like like if you go towards like San
Francisco let's say you start doing
Obama jokes making fun of chocolate
Jesus people get up all angry and they
cuz they think you're being racist but
it's like you're not you're just
questioning the guy holding the seat of
presidency and then you go let's say
they to Texas and you start doing George
Bush or Dick Cheney jokes people start
flipping out about that if they're going
to a comedy show it's not like you're
just like we're waking them up in their
apartment and insulting their favorite
politician it's so weird it's so weird
because they have similar political
views you start taking it personal it's
like it's people it's become like
rooting for a sports team everybody
likes to think oh I can laugh at myself
and I'm cool you know I'm down with
whatever you have to say but you know
when push comes to shove it doesn't
really happen that way would you say
that one side the lefties or the
righties or any better or worse at
laughing at themselves the progressives
will really come there too ready to be
offended they have so many rules to what
they're laughing at there's so much fine
print when it comes to political
correctness that they come to get
offended and it's obnoxious but then you
go somewhere and you do maybe some dirty
material and in some places they can get
really upset with that it's so
interesting so it depends on the
material but let me tell you something
so my place favorite places to perform
are red states considered red states
Texas can be a lot of fun because you go
up on stage you get dirty they go crazy
and they have fun a party let me tell
you your average Republican if you
really sat him down by himself he's
getting he's a libertarian if he really
is he's a libertarian if you really sit
him down you go to Arizona it's a
blood-red state they're really
libertarians
but they don't want to vote libertarian
cuz they they don't think they could win
as Ron Paul ever attended the naughty
college have Ron Paul I actually was
doing so National Lampoon radio and I
wanted Ron Paul on because I felt he was
such an amazing person and it was very
interesting when you were watching him
in the debates he would win the debate
and then of course they'd go to the
Talking Heads and they what you saw
there was a Ron Paul not able to uh get
across his met and you're like
everyone's like voting like who won Ron
Paul Ron Paul what was it about Ron
politics that appealed to you cuz he
said the things that I agree with the
Constitution you know I'm not into the
military-industrial complex have
accountability for these people who I
think are just ripping off the American
people blind and that all that resonated
with me and I voted for him I have this
dream of a Ron Paul Ross Perot Ralph
Nader and the Iron Sheik forming Voltron
and donkey punching to Washington DC
I'll always vote for the crazy old guy
with the weirdest conspiracy theories
for now on that's that's my goal when I
will never vote Republican or Democrat
ever again here's my plan
I want to rob a bank take all the money
go to a costume store buy all the
costumes donate them to homeless
shelters
okay you're not homeless sure how safe
would you feel if there's a superhero on
every corner honestly
Superman pass on a bench Aquaman
dumpster diving
Wonder Woman sucking for crack rock come
on that was a weird slow laugh in the
back but I'll take it
so what would that President Tripoli do
oh man that's easy I would make drugs
legal prostitution legal I'd make any
crime that doesn't hurt other people
pretty much legal so you're you're down
with the libertarian labels what do you
embrace that everybody's got little
things here and there but for the most
part yeah 100%
if you're not harming other people
what's the problem what do you make of
very prominent comics like Bill Maher
and Jon Stewart who seemed to be pretty
annoyed with the Tea Party he pissed me
off sometimes Bill Maher I like him I
like some of his stuff and I enjoy
watching his show in terms of they
brings on different kind of people on
you know and I enjoy that and when he's
wrong he gets hammered on it I don't
enjoy his hatred of middle Easterns and
Muslims because I find that you know
he's so sensitive about racism against
black people it's like how can you be
sensitive about that and then be totally
open about being racist against another
group of people it makes no sense at all
it's it's offensive to me so are you
willing to reveal that you're one of
those Middle Easterners well I'm
Armenian which is counts right what our
meanings are like in hobbits aren't they
they like they don't they're in one
little place they're nowhere else right
it's like Glendale is like the Shire
right anybody comics are supposed to be
rebels they're supposed to you know test
the system do you see that in your in
other comics or are they kind of freaked
out by political correctness too I find
that in in LA at least opinions hurt
your career what are some of the things
you can't say if you just have an
opinion on anything it's really
interesting that makes for great comedy
no opinions and that's why I think
comedy is
in the in the in the crapper right now
what about commercials that seems to be
a bastion of political correctness yeah
it's horrible it's all I mean like if I
see another beer commercial about guys
who are wearing short shorts and and
female bartenders telling us how
[ __ ] we are I'm gonna go nuts
have you seen that one beer commercial
we're like the ha aliens land yeah yeah
and they're like we're here to schmekel
it Kate with your men here's all the
beer you could ever want and of course
guys are just all they think about are
boobs and beer so like yeah and they run
on to the spacecraft now you wonder if
there's like a giant monster and they're
about to eat everything that walks on
board and then of course at the end just
to wrap it up because they don't want to
piss off chicks the the girl at the end
it's like they're now the guys are gone
it's like and what were we holding you
back from ladies what do you want a
scissor sister with your friends play
yourself in the living room what are we
holding you back from doing that you're
happy we're gone it drives me nuts dude
socially liberal you certainly existed
okay
I don't know what that word